- So, where did this idea for the
Kids Tonight Show come from?
- We grew up with shows
where kids were hosts,
Mickey Mouse Club
or even the Electric Company or Zoom
or whatever, the other
zoom and 3, 2, 1 Contact.
- The O.G.
- Yeah.
But right now, kids,
I have two little girls,
and they don't really have a show
where kids are hosts of things.
- Yeah.
And so I go,
we should do that.
Then I'm like, oh wait, I am a host.
We should have the Kids Tonight Show.
So we have four amazing
kids. They couldn't be cuter.
And they're a little 15
minute segments of the show.
So it's good bite size.
Perfect for parents who were like, okay,
one show and then you're
going to bed let's go.
- Amen. Yeah, I know that drill.
- You know? So we just figured,
we'd start it up. It's on Peacock.
And they interview celebrities.
They interview other kids.
There's music, it's messy,
It's fun.
It's just 15 minutes of joy
and pure fun family entertainment.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- And yeah, we lucked out.
It was a great, great, great, great show.
Top to bottom.
- [Kelly] It's such a brilliant idea.
- Lucky.
- Well, so the book you wrote,
which my kids love by the way.
It's your Christmas one.
- Oh.
- And it's a special now. Yeah.
- My daughter came home from school once,
and she was going to
her grandmother's house
for the weekend.
She was like,
"How many more sleeps till..."
shouldn't even have a lisp,
but I just added that.
- [Kelly] I was like,
wait, what's happening?
- Nah, nah, yeah she's cute.
She has a little lisp.
She's like, "How many more sleeps
till Grandma's house?"
How many more sleeps?
I never heard that.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. My
kids say that all the time.
That's why they love your book.
- [Jimmy] So I wrote the book
Five More Sleeps Till Christmas,
about a kid excited about Christmas.
And then it became now a animated show.
So it's a cartoon
- [Kelly] That's so cool
- like Charlie Brown
- or whatever.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's crazy. It airs the
day after Thanksgiving.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- So the 26th, it air's on
NBC and we made it and it's
like, kind of Claymation stop motion,
but also painted, the
animation is different
than anything you've seen.
It's about a boy and his dog
and his mom, and they get
a stranger is now involved
with their Christmas
and hopefully it doesn't
mess up any of his plans.
- Okay.
- Yeah. It's cute.
- Not stranger danger.
Cause that's kind of what--
- [Jimmy] No! Oh no, no.
- [Kelly] I'm just kidding.
My kids love, my kids love your book.
They love reading, we read
every night, so it's awesome,
cause there's not that many,
Christmas stories like that,
to be able to read to them. So.
- But I love your book too.
- [Kelly] Oh well, thank you.
- [Jimmy] Uh yeah.
- [Kelly] Well thank you.
Well, we're talking kids and
it's throwback Thursdays.
So how about let's look at you as a kid.
Cause I thought that'd be
fun. So here's this photo.
(Kelly laughing)
(Audience swoons)
- [Jimmy] Oh God. Oh my God.
Look at the acid wash Jean.
I don't even know
if that's acid wash.
- [Kelly] And it's like Reboks?
I don't know, it's awesome!
- [Jimmy] Yeah, something, yeah.
Something was on the discount rack.
I don't know all the whole outfit, but.
- We're all the ladies on you?
- [Kelly] I'm just kidding.
We're you just like --
- You know what happened?
Jimmy we found the perfect background,
this weird corner somewhere.
- With all the wood.
- Please take that photo off.
It was in high school
and I couldn't make the football team
or the baseball team.
I just wasn't that athletic.
but I wanted to play for a team.
And I remember someone
came on the announcement,
the loudspeaker, and if
anyone wants to play golf,
anyone, we would love
you for the golf team.
Or else we have to forfeit the
team. We won't have a team.
- So that's how you made a team?
(audience laughs)
- So that's how, that's how.
If I didn't make the team
there was no team.
- [Kelly] We literally can't!
- So I literally made the team.
That's right!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Hey. You got there. You got there.
- [Jimmy] That's how I got in.
And there would be no team.
- [Kelly] It was no audition.
- And I didn't even know how to golf.
And I remember as a kid in a week,
we used to grow tomatoes in our backyard.
And there were all these sticks
in the garden
to keep the tomatoes from falling over.
And one of them had like
a thing on the end of it.
And I said to my
grandfather, what is this?
And he goes, "It's a golf club.
You don't know what golfing...?"
- And yet, you made the
golf team! That's amazing!
- You think, totally ridiculous.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- I'm not good. Never, never
never became good, but I still play it.
And my grandpa's like,
"It's a good investment.
That's a good sport to
get into because you can
play it for the rest of your life."
- Well, I told you I'm into like top golf.
That's the kind of golf I'm into.
- [Jimmy] Yes.
- You've never been and
you're going to go with me.
- I would totally go with you.
- Okay, it'd be fun.
- I would love to do it.
I haven't done it yet.
- Yeah it's really, really fun.
Anyway, you drink, you
eat, you, you're married.
Do you remember your
very first comedy gig?
And were you terrified?
- I mean, yeah.
I used to do jokes around the
house. My family, you know,
they would give me 50 cents or a dollar.
- [Kelly] Really?
- And just go do Rodney
Dangerfield or something.
And I be like, oh, tell
you all right, okay.
My wife's cooking so bad. I mean, uh,
since when does toast have bones?
And so I do that, but my first big gig,
my mom heard about an
impression contest on the radio.
And she said, "Jimmy,
I know you do all these voices
in your in your bedroom, I can hear you."
- [Kelly] Your--
There's so many jokes!
- Yeah, how thin are these walls? Yeah.
What else you hear in
there mom? Uh, anyways.
So she goes, but why don't
you enter this contest
as to who can do the best
impression in the Hudson Valley?
And I went to this club
called Bananas in Poughkeepsie
and I was 17, I think I want to say?
I was a senior in high school.
And I went and I did all
these voices for a spokesman,
for a troll doll someone gave me
for graduating.
I don't know what to do with this doll.
So I just made it act out of it.
So I'd be like,
Uh, who wants to be a
spokesman for the troll doll?
First up,
uh, I would do like a Adam
Sandler and I'd be like,
(speaking gibberish)
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
- Or John Travolta, I'm
like, who does his hair?
this thing is like so crazy,
what kind of troll doll is
this?? It's crazy hair right?
Next up, Seinfeld.
Oh who plays with these dolls?
The arms and legs don't
move! This isn't a doll!
[Jimmy] You know,
And I ended up, I ended up winning.
I won first place. I
won a thousand dollars.
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
(audience applauding)
- A thousand dollars when
you're 17 is like the lottery.
- And then it got the
gigs that my dad would
drive me to the gigs.
I would host weekend shows--
- [Kelly] That's so cool and supportive.
- They were, I mean,
(audience laughs)
well I mean they were,
but, they were like, Jimmy, this is great.
I think, you know, you
should go to college
and think about something else.
You know, just have a backup.
They made me take the postal exam
- Okay.
- And I could've worked
for the us postal service, easy.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, instead --
- [Kelly] So you had a backup plan.
- [Jimmy] I had --
- [Kelly] Yeah, for when --
- [Jimmy] Three back up plans.
And so I ended up
luckily being a comedian.
I moved out to LA to do acting classes,
which you can tell how good of an actor
have you seen my movies?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You are!
- No one has, no.
- I find that comedians
are -- y'all can go deeper
than anyone else to me,
and even think of your favorite actors.
Like one of mine is Meryl.
Okay. So funny, her
comedic timing is genius.
She's so funny. Like you have to be witty.
You have to be of a certain
level of intelligence
to be that kind of witty
and that kind of great actor, I think.
- Well...
(audience laughs)
- What's happening?
- I appreciate it. I appreciate it.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And I appreciate it. I promised
myself I wouldn't do this.
I appreciate everything that
you've ever done for me.
I love you, Kelly.
- So maybe you should
have been a postal worker.
- Okay, yeah.